hy lake bei euch jetzt ein neuer tag auf
herzlich willkommen zu einem neuen video
auf einem kanal ihr seht es bereits hier
in der konstellation wir sehen uns auch
dort das ist max das ist sebastian das
bin ich und wir spielen eine neue runde
gang hiess
schön dass wir hier sind dann gut ihre
musik vorstellen ich bin helm oder eben
war zweiter stein hendrik dreck von
recanati
[Musik]
das ist wenn man das mal raus springen
dass man automatisch die sache wieder
sei nicht fair
auch direkt meine hände
[Applaus]
wir haben gerade
wir konzentrieren uns mehr
[Gelächter]
aber immer
[Applaus]
der tod spielt der film macht ihr wieder
team gehen händler
das erst mal hier rein kommt hilft
dieses mal wirklich mit ja komplettieren
erstmal muss man den leuten
da hätte
[Musik]
runter mit dir ein paar sekunden später
hätte ich beide
[Musik]
wir müssen helm laster okay okay aber
nicht schlecht jetzt jeder am punkt oder
vielleicht oder keine reine das tut das
spiel hat schon geschenkt wir warten auf
dem brot gericht abgeholt oder
festgehalten
hierbei war ich habe nicht die ganze
getan ich kann eigentlich die steuer
geben aber ja ich hole auf ich will
jetzt auch
hallo
zwischen diesen so billig da noch wer
bin ich
die runde einfach geworden in dem wir
weiter verschwunden sind ich habe das
spiel seit zwei jahren
aber ich habe keinen einzigen sind das
ist diese übel schwerem butt hält die
ganze zeit runter
das erstmal wirklich erwarten die
stimmung genießen hatte das erst mal
kurz gegen helmut und mein gott warum
habt ihr hin und nicht einfach
hochkommen lassen
die punkte an das teams machen
ich mache gegen weißwasser wand
hochklettern
[Gelächter]
[Applaus]
ganz kurz stehen bleibt daumen nicht
stehen jetzt darauf vielleicht ein leben
lang weiter weg vor sich habe jetzt
warte ich hab's aber er fällt da nicht
rein wie mache ich das denn es muss doch
irgendwie klappen
mein erster punkt an canali mit wirklich
macht haben
[Musik]
macht gar keiner ist der letzte punkt
gemacht
ich nehme mir nicht nehmen wie kann der
sich nach hätten ich weiß wieder
hochgeht aber wie schweiß mann war ich
weiß es auch nicht das weiß noch wie ich
hab's luke hat die ganze zeit gesagt
erlegen
gerettet habe in der luft wie kann das
denn sein
daneben schon geklettert
das ist genug zeit raus gesagt wie ich
werde irgendwie ich hole es aber auf 123
3 ich gehe erst mal sowas von in diesem
jahr die kommende hochwasser ich glaube
da hat nicht richtig einfach würstchen
und dem magdeburger wurst in der mitte
da unten schöne größte umfasste band
ich bin darf ich dein tod noch man das
draußen
[Musik]
oh mein gott wenn nicht gar nichts mehr
ich bewege mich keinen sinn
gleichzeitig habe ich mich ein bisschen
vor achtet drauf ich drücke man kann man
nach rechts ist ein loch in diesem tust
du auch unter gefallen
ohne entschieden bist du gleichzeitig
auch unter gefallen ich war eigentlich
jubel weil ich gewarnt habe aber dann
ist auch ein glück
[Musik]
an der stelle wenn wir das video bereits
gefallen hat leicht aber details weiter
schreibt
[Musik]